翻訳: Mari Arimitsu
校正: Hiroko Kawano
どうも 皆さんこんにちは
『ふうせん宇宙撮影』の岩谷圭介です
今日は『ふうせん宇宙撮影』の話を
少しさせていただきたいなと思います
突然ですが皆さん 子どもの頃の
夢って何だったでしょうか？
私はですね 子どもの頃から
理科が大好きで 宇宙も好きでした
そして実験することが好きです
何かを作ることが大好きでした
そんな子ども時代の私が
憧れていた人 ―
「ザ・なりたい大人」という人がいまして
こちらの人です きっと皆さん
ご存知のことかと思います
『バック・トゥ・ザ・フューチャー』の
エメット・ブラウン博士ですね
彼のようは発明家というか
科学者ですか —
あのような 自分自身で
やりたいことを突き詰めて
そして自分が作った装置に囲まれて
生活しているような
彼の姿に 私はすごく憧れていました
そして「彼のような大人になりたいな」と
ずっとずっと思っていたんですが
大人になるにつれて
彼のような職業が無いことに気づき
彼のようになるには どうしたらいいか
分からなくなってしまいました
そして大学４年まで
ずっと行ってしまうんですが
そんな中 出会ったものが
風船を使った宇宙撮影でした
これは外国の大学生が
自分自身で作った装置で
アメリカの学生が
宇宙を撮影したよという
小さな小さなニュースだったんですが
海外のニュースサイトで
偶然 インターネットをしていたら
見つけまして
そのニュースを見て
私はとても大きな衝撃を受けました
宇宙開発というと 通常国家事業なので
膨大な予算がかかるもので
到底 個人でできるものだとは
思っていませんでした
その固定概念が破壊されたんです
「自分自身もやってみたい」
と思って始めたのが
もともとの一番最初です
やはり自分自身が子どもの頃から
宇宙が好きだった
何かものを作りたい ―
発明家になりたいというのが
上手く交わったのが このバルーンを使った
宇宙撮影だったんですね
そして「やってみたい」と
思ったのはいいんですが
先例が何もありません
今はインターネットが普及して
とても便利な時代です
調べれば大概のことは見つかります
ただ何もやったことがないものに関しては
見つけることができないんです
そしたらどうしよう？
やっぱり やってみるしかないんです
「とりあえず やってみよう」
ということで まず材料探しです
宇宙開発をしようと思って
100円ショップや
手芸屋さん 東急ハンズ —
到底考えられないような場所なんですが
とりあえず 手元にあるものから
作ってみようと思い
一番初めの装置を作ってみました
カメラも大したものは使っていません —
こういう白い球体の中に
バルーンを使って カメラを積んでいたという
情報だけはあったので
その２つの情報をもとに
作ってみました
これで白い球体の物体が
出来上がったんですが
出来上がったものを
ふと見て気づいたんですよ
「これ飛んで行ったら
なくなっちゃうんじゃないの」と
なくなってしまったら困りますから —
例えばヒモを付ければ
どこかに行くこともないんじゃないか
という風に考えまして
ヒモを付けるんだったら 巻き戻しの
装置があると楽チンなんですよ
巻き戻しの装置で身近なものというと
釣り具屋さんにありますね
リールです
リールがいいんじゃないかなと
釣り具屋さんに行ってみましたら
私が求めるリールが
10万円くらいしたんですよ
10万円は学生でお金もなかった中の
開発なので とても出せる金額じゃないです
ここで諦めるかというと
そういう訳にもいきませんから
ちょっと家に帰って考えます
家に帰って床をふと見ると
リールのような形の物が
落ちているんですよね
ゴミ取りのコロコロです
コロコロを回すと
リールっぽくなるんですよ
そのまま巻くと大変なので
段ボールを巻いて直径を大きくして
少しラクにしようという風に考えて
このようにリールを作り上げました
初め10万円かかると言われましたが
100円もかかりませんでした
ありがとうございます
そして順調に進んでいるような
順調じゃないような感じなんですが
このようにヘリウムボンベが必要なんです
風船を膨らませるためには
ヘリウムガスが必要です
ヘリウムボンベが家に届いて
さあ実験をしようと思ってボンベを見ると
重たいんですよね —
何十キロもあるんです
とてもとても運べるものではありません
「ではこの実験どうしよう？」と
実験しようにもできないなと
思ったんですが —
これは ふと気づいて困ったんですが
バルーンを自転車にくくりつけて
持って行ってしまえば
ボンベを持っていかないから
楽なんじゃないかということで
このようにバルーンを
自転車にくくりつけて
私は街の中を走って
実験場所まで行ったんですよ
当然 街の人からは
「あの人なんだろう」と思われるんですが
バルーンが付いていて愉快なだけですし
誰にも迷惑を掛けていませんから
お構いなくやってしまいました
そして向かった先が
北海道大学の裏庭です
私自身 北海道大学に在籍していましたし
調べてみると北海道大学の校則に
「裏庭で風船をあげてはいけません」と
書いてありませんから
こちらを問題なく
使わせてもらいました
実験の風景です —
このように一番初めに飛ばした装置ですね
普通のパーティー用の
バルーンを使っています
優雅に上がっているように
見えますよね
これは全然 [そうではなく]
大失敗でした
上げてみたものが ―
バルーン同士がぶつかり合ってしまうんですよ
ぶつかって ぶつかって 全て
その振動がカメラに伝わってしまうので
撮れた映像が本当に『ムンクの叫び』
のようなものになってしまっていて
良いカットは何もないです —
見ていて気持ち悪くなります
これは大失敗でした
しかし やっぱり
やってみると分かるんです
例えば装置を作ってみないと
分からなかった
ボンベが来て分かった —
そしてリールが無いんだったら
作ってみて分かった —
リールが使えなかったかもしれません
やってみたからわかったんです
この装置も作ってみたから
上手くいくかどうかが分かったんです
まず「やってみる」ことからはじめると
始めは考えていても分からないです —
一歩進むと また一歩違うものが見えます
もう一歩進むとまた見えてくるので
ここは失敗したっていいんです
どんどんどんどん先に進めるんです
「やってみる」ことがすごい大事だ
ということを学びました
そこから３号機、４号機と
どんどん作っていくんですが
１号機はヒモを付けていました
２号機、３号機もヒモを付けました
ヒモを付けていると 宇宙を撮れない
ということが分かったんですよ
それで宇宙を撮るためには 空に
放たなければいけなくなったんですが
空に放てば どこかに
飛んで行ってしまいます
装置もどんどん大掛かりに
なってしまうので
自分一人でやるのは
ちょっと大変になってきました
それで仲間を探そうと思って
学友なり 知っている大人なりに
色々声を掛けました
風船で宇宙を撮ろうと思っているんだ
やってみたいと思っているんだと
仲間が見つかると思いました
どうやら考えが甘かったようです
皆から言われました
「そんなことやって何になるの？」と
「お金にもならないし 時間もかかるし
労力もかかるし
それで得る物が何もないのに
なんでやるの？」とか
「他の人がやってないんだったら
それは出来ないことか
価値のないことなんだよ」と
すごい言われました
でも他の人がやりたいことじゃないんです
理解が得られなくても仕方がないんです
私自身がやりたいことなんです
なので引き続き
一人でやることになりました
空に放ってしまうと
どこかに行ってしまうので
場所を見つけないといけません —
仕方がないのでGPSという
便利な機械が今はあるので
それを詰め込むことにしました
GPSを詰めてもいいんですが
どこに行くか ある程度目当てをつけないと
例えば山の中、海の中に落ちると
見つからなくなってしまいます
なので ある程度
目当てをつけることにしました
札幌市から上げて 東側には
広大な農地が広がっています
この辺りに落ちてくれれば
おそらく回収できるんじゃないかと
この風の予測も ジェット気流
というものがあるとか
あと偏西風というものが
吹いているとか
そんな情報が
何となく頭の中にあったので
多分 東に流れてくれるだろうという
非常にいい加減な予測の上で
実験をしてみました
さあ飛ばしてみました
飛ばしてみて心配なので
GPSで場所を確認してみます
するとですね —
恵庭とか出てくるんです
恵庭は札幌の南にあるんですよね
こんなはずはないんですよ —
おかしいんですよ
「これは機械の誤差だろう」
と私は思い
もう一回 検索をかけてみました
そうしたら支笏湖の西側にいるんですよね
更におかしな方向に飛んで行っています
これは何か悪い夢だと思って
もう一度検索をかけると
室蘭沖に落ちているんですよね —
海上に落ちています
これは飛行経路なんですけれど
このように飛んで ここの海の上に
落っこちてしまいました
はじめの予想地点はここです —
予想と全然違います
もうこれは到底無理だなと
私は思い知らされました
やっぱり外国の大学生が
優秀だったから できたんだろうとか
色んな人に言われたことが
正しかったのかもしれないとか
自分自身の挑戦が
無謀だったのかもしれないとか
色々悩みました
それでですね 10日間位経った日
突然 苫小牧の人から電話が来たんですよ
何だろうと思って 電話をとってみると
「あなたの気球を海岸で拾いましたよ」と
ここから流れてきたんですよね —
苫小牧まで
そして偶然流れ着いたものが
偶然 親切な人に拾われて
しかもそのデータが
偶然 壊れていなかったんです
そちらが この映像です —
札幌市から上げまして
どんどんどんどん街の様子が
離れていきますね
そして どんどんどんどん離れていって —
後ろに見えるのが羊蹄山ですね —
見えるはずのない支笏湖が見えてきて —
（笑）
支笏湖です —
ここで映像は止まっていたんですが
偶然 本当に幸運に恵まれて
４号機が返ってきました
その４号機を手にして
私はそれまで到底無理だと思っていた —
諦めかけていました —
これを手にして
「もう少し頑張ってみたら」と
誰かに言われたような気がしましたので
私はもう少し
頑張ってみることにしました
そこから一年間です
16号機で ようやく自分自身で撮りたい
宇宙の画を撮れるようになりました
そこまで15号機
延々と失敗を繰り返します
こちらはニセコから上げたんですよ
そしてどんどんどんどん上がっていき
ちょっとずつ宇宙の景色になり ―
これ上に見える白いものはバルーンです
そして北海道の西側が見えますね
洞爺湖が美しく輝いています
このような景色を撮って
バルーンが破裂して帰ってきました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
この一連の経験を通して 私は失敗しても
めげずにずっと続けていれば
いつか宇宙ですら成功できる
ということを学びました
さて現在ではもう ここから
さらに色々なものを作っていき
64機の装置を作っています
日本一たくさん失敗しています
日本一たくさん成功もしています
やはり失敗というものは
避けるもののように言われていますが
失敗は悪いものではありません
成功する場合にも色々ありますが
偶然成功してしまうよりは 失敗した方が
いいことを教えてくれるんですよ
偶然成功してしまった場合は
何が悪かったのか教えてくれません
失敗は色んな悪かった所を
教えてくれるので さらに先に進めます
やってみることで どんどんどんどん
先に進んでいけるんです
そして最近の『ふうせん宇宙撮影』
どのようになっているか
１つ ショートムービーを作りましたので
お見せしたいと思います
（ビデオ）
岩谷：こちらですね 十勝平野の草原です
一面 人工物は何もありません
この場所に装置が落下しているんですよ —
それを私は探しています
この場所に偶然
落ちたわけではありません
私が当日の風を予測し
そしてここに落ちるように
全て計算した上で
この場所に落としています
このような装置です —
白い球体です
発泡スチロールで包まれています
中にはカメラが入っています
元々 昔はトイカメラという
小さいカメラを使っていたんですが
最近はプロが使うようなカメラも
全て動かすことができるので
世界一美しい映像を
撮ることができるんですね
このような大きなバルーンに
[球体を] 吊るしているだけです
球体の中にはカメラやGPS その他
もろもろの機器などが入っています
このバルーンは 大体 今1.6メートル
２メートルくらいの大きさなんですが
上空に上がっていくにつれ
気圧が低下していくので
風船がどんどんどんどん
大きくなっていきます
この打ち上げなんですが
空を飛んでいます —
空を飛んでいますので
色々な国内法に関わります
例えば 航空法ですね —
そういったものにも全て申請を出した上で
許可をもらって打ち上げをしています
風船はだんだんだんだん
上がっていくんですが
雲に入っていくんですけど これが
どの位の速度で上がっていくかというと
大体時速20キロです 時速20キロで
私たちの[周りで]身近なものというと
自転車ですね
車で運転して外の景色を見ていても
あまり景色を覚えられません
自転車で運転していると
大体景色を覚えていますよね
空の遊覧をするのに一番良い速度は
風船くらいの速度なんです
ロケットだと ちょっと速すぎて
ほとんどすぐ通り過ぎてしまうので
見ることができません —
『ふうせん宇宙撮影』の醍醐味がここですね
そしてどんどんどんどん
高度を上げていきます
現状 かなり冷えてきましたね
マイナス50、60、70度と
冷えてくるんですが
この位の気温になってしまうと
機械は全てバッテリーで動いているんですが
バッテリーが動かなくなってしまいます
私は様々な機械を上空で動かしたいので
そのバッテリーを無理やり
動かすことができるような発明品を
自分自身で作り上げることで 様々な機械を
動かすことができるようになっています
このように ちょっと曇ったりしていますけど
なかなかこの辺に来ると
不思議な自然現象が見られたりします
例えば 私たちに身近な水がありますね
水はですね —
この高度に来ると
常温のまま沸騰して 凍るんです
とても不思議なことが起こるんです
なので 気温が低いんですけれど
１回凍った水が溶けて
このように気化しています
このまま順調に風船は上がり続けます
そして毎回目指している高度
というのがありまして
おおよそ３万メートル位の
高度を目指しています
これがちょうど
３万メートル位の高度です
なぜ３万メートルの高度を
目指しているかというと
３万メートルまで行くと
私たちの住んでいる —
この場所と比べて
空気が100分の1程度しかありません
なので 空気に邪魔されずに
撮影ができる環境なんです
ちなみに私たちがこの場所まで
行ってしまうと 死んでしまいますので
当然宇宙服のようなものを
着ないといけません
私たち生物にとっては 宇宙と
何も変わりのない環境ですね
そしてこの高度まで上がると
先ほどの1.6メーターから
２メーター位の風船ですね —
あれがもの凄く巨大化しています
体積比にして 80倍から90倍位の
大きさまで大きくなって
それが耐えきれずに 破裂してしまいます
そしてそこから —
空気がない場所なので
抵抗を受けずに真っ直ぐ落ちていきます
真っ直ぐに落ちてくる
この時の速度が
おおよそ時速千キロ以上の速度です
マッハは音速を超える位の速度ですね
荒ぶってます —
そして落ちてくるんですが
それがそのまま地上に
落下してしまっては危険ですので
ちゃんと安全に落下するように
装置が作られています
大きなパラシュートが付いていまして
それによって ふんわりと
落ちるようになっています
こちら回収のシーンなんですが
このような小麦畑で回収できる
発泡スチロールの球体は
全く傷ついていませんね
このように安全に回収できるんです
（ビデオ終了）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
さて何度も『ふうせん宇宙撮影』
という言葉を使っていますが
『ふうせん宇宙撮影』とは
そもそも何なのかというと
簡単に言ってしまうと 風船を使った
世界一安全な宇宙開発です
そして おそらく世界一
小さな宇宙開発です
なので 例えば このように子供が
近場でやることもできます 安全です
このように色んな人が
手軽に出来てしまう宇宙開発です
これをどんどん広げていきたいですね
ということで 今後の展開なんですが
私自身はこの宇宙撮影
宇宙に誰でも触れられるように
この宇宙撮影を
使っていきたいなと思っています
例えばこの２枚の写真は
私が撮影したものではありません
今年 私が高校生に教えることで
日本の２校の高校生の子たちに
成功させてもらいました
このように学生時代に
到底不可能そうな宇宙というものを
成功させることによって
自分自身で何でもできるんだということを
経験してもらえたらいいなと思っています
きっとその子の人生において
大きなものになり
将来色んなものに挑戦できる若者が
増えていったら ―
そうなってもらえたら
いいなという風に思い
私はこの方法を公開することで
沢山の人に触れてもらいたいなと思っています
またこちらパラシュートです
先ほどの上空で パラシュートが
展開している時の様子なんですが
さぞ特別なパラシュートと
思われるかもしれません
これ ゴミ袋とガムテープと
スズランテープでできています
一枚百円 かかっていません
このパラシュートは
こんな物で耐えてしまうんですよ
ちょっと裏話がありまして
このパラシュート 何も言わずに
JAXAの方に見せたことがあります
「これどう思います？
使えると思います？」と聞いたら
「いや無理無理」と言われたんですよ
「これ落ちてきたやつですよ」と言ったら
「えーっ、嘘！」という話だったので
意外と動くということを
知らなかったりするんですが
意外とこんな物で作れてしまうんですが
この簡単なパラシュート
実際に子ども達に作ってもらう
ワークショップ等もやっています
やっぱり科学というものを
乾燥した状態で —
教科書から学ぶと
なかなか受け付けません
しかし科学は 元々
自然から持ってきたものです
自然の要素を切り出してきたものです
なので一回自然に立ち返って自分自身で
自然に触れることで 科学を学んでくれると
より科学を身近に感じて もっともっと
好きになってくれるんじゃないか
そして自分自身が宇宙開発にも
携われるんだということを感じてもらうことで
色んなことに 挑戦することができる
子ども達が増えていったらいいなと思い
こんな活動もしています
こういったものも全て 私自身の
ホームページで公開していまして
もっと沢山の人に できるように
なってもらいたいと思っております
そして私自身は 体験する宇宙が
できたらいいなと思っていまして
例えばこれ パノラマ映像です —
360度のパノラマ
もしくは全天球のパノラマ等もあるんですが
こういったものを 例えばですね ―
エレベーターの中に全天投影することで
一階から最上階に行くにつれて
どんどん宇宙に近づいていくような
エレベーターがあったら
単なる移動手段でしかないエレベーターが
ちょっと幸せな空間になるじゃないですか
「宇宙を身近に感じる」もありますが
ちょっとした喜びを届けられるようなものを
宇宙を使って 作っていけたら
いいなと思っています
そして これが札幌市の
青少年科学館でやった
このようなプラネタリウム公演も
できていますね
このようなプラネタリウム用の
コンテンツを作り
日本中に配信できたらいいなと
思っています
さて私自身の夢ですが 来年度は
深海への挑戦をしたいと思っています
上の次は下かという 非常に安直な
考えのように感じるかもしれませんが
私自身 自然科学が大好きです
上の探求はしましたので
次は下の探求をして —
下には生物がいます —
新しい生き物がいます
新しい生き物を見つけて
適当な名前をつけてみたいですね
色んな実験をしてみたいです
私自身がそういった色んなものを探求して
それを達成していくことを見てもらうことで
私がやった宇宙のことを
高校生たちなり 小学生たちなり
そういった子たちが
私の姿を見ることで
もっと色んなことに挑戦して
何でもできるんだなということを
感じてもらえたらいいなと思っています
さて 皆さんに今日一つだけ
覚えて帰っていただきたい言葉があります
それは「やってみる」から
はじめよう！という言葉です
何事もやってみれば始まります
やってみることで分かることって沢山あります
ですので まずやってみては
どうでしょうか
皆さんご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）